now it's 10 years today since the
Entertainment Group AG took over the
long-term lease and running of the o2
previously known as the Millennium Dome
it's now the world's busiest music venue
and one of London's most popular visitor
attractions I climbed to the roof of the
o2 to hear more from Tom Mesereau den
Madrid mi Zirin Deena got my teeth back
in the president and chief executive of
AG Europe began by asking him if brexit
made him worry about future investment
at the site no we've never been
concerned about that we believe we
believe in the United the UK we believe
in London we believe that there's a
great future here we but we believe that
business will continue to grow and
prosper here people want to be
entertained they want to have a good
night out we offer that well I think
what makes it resilient here is just the
entertainment that's offered we have
international superstars that appear
here regularly tomorrow night and the
next night we'll have Celine you know
last week we you know we had some great
we had take that so there's a lot of
great artists that that play here of
every genre of every kind we've had
everything from you know walking you
know walking with dinosaurs to the ATP
World Tennis so ten years ago this week
that you've got the keys to this place
what was it like back then I do recall
the first time I ever walked into the
tent when it was empty before anything
was built truly amazing a 22-acre tent
with nothing in it
it was really a sight to behold when I
walked in I knew that we had potential
here and we had done something similar
in Los Angeles where we took what is now
the Staples Center in the surrounding
area in downtown Los Angeles and created
a destination created an entertainment
destination and I could see the same
thing happening here because of course
previously they didn't able to
Millennium Dome it was a bit of an
inglorious failure there there was a
moment in time where I think a lot of
people were second-guessing what may
have been done back then and I think
they were happy to have us take it over
I don't think anybody ever envisioned
what this would turn out to be the
number one music destination in the
world we'd sell more tickets here at the
o2 than anywhere else in the world so
how much have you invested in total in
excess of 500 million pounds
this is I'm right I think I'm right in
saying your biggest investment worldwide
it is it is we're very proud of it to
stand up here at the top of it really is
that is a great moment for myself even
to look around to see everything that's
been developed on the peninsula it's
quite a sight we typically have about
two and a half million people that buy
tickets to attend events plus another
million for the for the cinema in
addition to that we probably have in
total including those previous numbers
about nine million people that that come
through the the tenth each and every
year
we currently create about five hundred
million pounds of economic benefit to
London in the greater area do you think
there were any lessons from the recent
Manchester attack in terms of security I
think that there's always lessons I
think every day we're learning more
about what we need to do to protect the
consumers the people that buy tickets to
come to our events I think that all of
the entertainment industry not just
ourselves are very vigilant we're taking
new steps new procedures and we're
enhancing the procedures that we already
have in place to make the consumer the
ticket buyer feel feel comfortable it
security hasn't been an issue in visitor
numbers I mean obviously everybody in
industry is concerned about the recent
attacks we continually update our
procedures and protocol we're very very
careful about what we do we educate both
our staff and the people are coming to
visit us we were among the first we were
the first to install metal detectors at
our entrance initially some people were
a little bothered by that they've come
to accept it and appreciate it now